bob woodward releases a bombshell tape
of president trump talking about down
playing covet
democrats ignore their own records to
leap on trump's failures and politics
continue to dominate facts when it comes
to covid i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all of the breaking news in
just one moment first let's talk about
the fact there's a lot of uncertainty in
the market right now you may notice the
stock market
moving up and down like a yoyo and that
is not unexpected i mean what we are
watching right now is a lot of new data
being priced into the system but times
of great volatility times of
not knowing what to expect those are
times when you might want to diversify
at least a little bit into precious
metals i've been telling you since 2016
to invest at least a little bit of your
money
in gold and to invest in gold with my
friends over at birch gold that was back
when gold was 1300 bucks an ounce now it
is hovering
around historic highs and look what's
coming around the corner a presidential
election there could be urban unrest
it could be rural unrest there could be
multiple contentious seats in the senate
they could flip
if biden loses the election do you
really think the democrats are going to
let it go if trump loses the election
and it's an arrow do you think that
things are going to go
really really great well now would be a
good time to think about that portfolio
if you haven't reached out to birch gold
it's diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira
or just purchase a little bit of
physical silver or gold from them
do it today text bend 47 47 47 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings with gold
i've got gold i trust birch gold the
people you should trust as well tech ben
247 4747
open a precious metals ira today again
text ben to 47
47 47. okay so big news of yesterday and
into today
are the woodward tapes bob woodward has
tapes of talking with president trump
now
first question who in the hell thought
it was a good idea for trump to talk to
bob woodward
who in the hell thought that it was a
good idea for trump to ever talk to
members of the press
see trump has this very bizarre
relationship with the press where he
really hates them because they mistreat
him and because they lie about him but
also he loves them
i mean really loves them and wants to
talk to them all the time
and so this means that the white house
press office is basically woody in toy
story 4 trying to prevent forkey from
throwing himself in the trash
that is every day for the white house
press office because they're
out there just trying to message just
trying to get on message about joe biden
and and riots and kenosha and
unrest and the economy teetering and and
there's trump
out there just doing his thing trying to
throw himself in the trash trash
just jumping into the trash like forky
from from toy story 4. and if you're the
white house press office
the comms office you have to be
incredibly frustrated at this point
especially because we are now two months
out from an election
and you've got donald trump as it turns
out doing 18 hours
18 hours of on the record interviews
with bob woodward
now i sort of understand the logic i
guess i guess
in that bob woodward is a
pseudo-journalist
when i say pseudo-journalist i mean that
the last several books he's written have
come under serious question
for decontextualizing comments and then
recontextualizing them improperly
and he'll report rumors he he doesn't
footnote his stuff
he's sort of famous for this the bob
woodward's books are you know
seen as sort of inside stories of what's
going on inside various administrations
but as matthew walter put it over at the
week
the problem is that he'll just print
rumor when he can't get the fact
he will print second-hand stories and
this is something bob woodward is famous
for so
that means that if you want to stop him
from doing that you give him firsthand
sourcing well there's only one problem
with that which is that it doesn't
dissuade him
from violating things like on the record
or off the record or on background
versus on the record
and he'll just do whatever he wants to
do and letting the chicken
let it letting the fox into the henhouse
is a really bad idea particularly with
president trump who is fond of
overstating things and fond of saying
silly things he is a real estate magnate
with a gift for puffery in the real
estate business you're constantly
puffing up the real estate isn't this
the most beautiful
island kitchen look at the open look at
the open floor plan my god i've never
seen anything
puffery is the nature of real estate and
donald trump is the nature of puffery so
donald trump has a couple of personality
flaws that come out in nearly every
interview
and they can make for a very toxic
combination personality flaw number one
the man has never admitted he was wrong
ever he is never wrong according to
donald trump he has never had reason to
repent before god
according to donald trump he has never
done a thing in his entire career that
is wrong
and personality flaw number two he
engages in puffery so everything is
superlative it's
the worst or the best is it spectacular
unbelievable
garbage there is no in-between for
president trump
when you combine those two personality
flaws one he's never done anything wrong
with two
his penchant for puffery you end up with
some very unfortunate quotes
about covid and that is what happened
here with regard to
bob woodward's book so there are two
allegations that put together
make for some toxic politics for trump
allegation number one is one that
woodward puts in
the book apparently he spoke with trump
on february 7th
his new book is titled rage of course
apparently
trump said to woodward about covet quote
this is deadly stuff
in a series of interviews with woodward
said cnn trump revealed that he had a
surprising level of detail about the
threat of the virus earlier than
previously known
pretty amazing trump told woodward
adding that the coronavirus was maybe
five times
more deadly than the flu apparently
he also suggested that the virus was
airborne at the time
now here is the thing about all the
stuff that trump was saying on february
7th
if trump had come out publicly and said
that the virus was airborne on february
7th everybody rightly would have said
that this was not actually th this was
not
actually supremely telling because
donald trump has said a lot of things
about covet many of which are inaccurate
okay it turns out that the who did not
declare that the virus is airborne until
july
so if trump would come out in february
like the beginning of february he said
okay we need to shut down all of
american society the virus is airborne
how many people do you think would have
gone along with that the answer pretty
obviously is zero since about
one week prior the democratic party had
opposed trump even shutting down some
travel from china when you hear
democrats proclaim they would have done
something very very differently in
february the answer is no you wouldn't
have
nancy pelosi was out in chinatown
encouraging people to come on down
february 24th so we'll get to the
democratic response to all this
in just one second okay so he is on tape
with woodward on february 7th where he
said that
the virus is dangerous and that it is it
is airborne
and that it could kill a lot of people
now again
how much of that is trump conveying what
he actually knew and how much of that is
trump
misconveying what he had heard we've
seen enough of his press conferences to
know that he was constantly giving
you know either best case or worst case
scenario and nothing in between there
was never any moderate rhetoric coming
from trump
about the about the virus but he did on
february 7th apparently
say that it was airborne and woodward
says this was a damning
missed opportunity for trump to reset
the leadership clock after he was told
this is a once-in-a-lifetime
health emergency during a pre-super bowl
interview on fox news february 2nd trump
said we pretty much shut it down coming
in
from china and two days later during the
state of the union trump made only a
passing reference to the virus he
promised quote my administration will
take all necessary steps to safeguard
our citizens from this threat okay and
then
there is another tape that emerged a
little bit later on this would be march
19th and in this later tape trump was
asked by woodward
what changed between you know february
and march where you really started to
ramp up
the rhetoric now the normal answer here
is the information changed right that is
the normal answer
back in february we had basically zero
debt not basically we had zero
identified deaths
from coveted in the united states in
february at that point it's only later
we realized that we may have
had some deaths from cove that we hadn't
properly identified but there were
double-digit cases in the united states
as of february there were very low
double-digit deaths of early march
all trump had to say here is we got new
information and therefore i changed my
my
feelings about the virus but again go
back to those two personality flaws
trump has never been wrong according to
trump and two everything is either the
worst or the best
well that means that what you're about
to hear him safe it's well within
his personality foibles one he has never
been wrong at any point in time he is
omniscient and therefore knew from the
very beginning how deadly this virus was
which leads him to have to now explain
okay if you knew it was that deadly then
why exactly didn't you talk about it
which leads him to say well the reason i
didn't talk about it
is because i didn't want to panic
everybody which is a pretty weak excuse
i mean honestly if you knew that things
were super duper bad back in february
you should have said so because
americans
ought to be trusted with information i
don't care if you're a democrat
president or republican president
if you know really bad information that
affects americans you have a
responsibility to pass that along to
americans
it is not your job to tell us whether or
not to panic it is your job
to tell us exactly what we are needing
to know so we can make our own risk
assessments
right that's why if you look at the
actual charts on on human movements in
the united states you'll see that people
started to shut down their own travel
plans
before all of the government lockdowns
took place okay so anyway
those two personalities foibles combined
to give you this tape which will be used
by democrats in every attack ad from now
until the election
now it's turning out it's not just old
people bob just today and yesterday
some startling facts came out it's not
just old old
yeah exactly people to plenty of young
people so
what's going on give me an a moment of
talking to somebody going through this
with faushi
or somebody who kind of uh
it caused a pivot in your mind because
it's clear just from
what's in on the public record that you
went through
a pivot on this to oh my god the gravity
is uh almost inexplicable and
unexplainable well i think bob really
to be honest with you sure i want you to
i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
yes sir because i don't want to create a
panic
right okay so that is the last quote
right i always want to play it down i
still like playing it down
right that is going to be the poll quote
they'll ignore the last part where he
justifies it by saying that he didn't
want to create a panic by the way that
sort of rationale has been used
also by dr anthony fauci when he said
that people shouldn't mask because he
didn't want to create a run on the masks
that logic was also used by chris by
andrew cuomo the governor of new york as
we will see
but suffice it to say that the combo of
those two factors one
trump saying woodward in early february
that he talked to xi jinping
and quote it goes through the air it's
always tougher than the touch you don't
have to touch things right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
delicate one it's also more deadly than
even your
strenuous flu right that combined with
the
march 19 statement that he had purposely
downplayed the virus is going to lead
the democrats to say
trump knew and he didn't do anything
about it and he was lying to us about
this whole thing the entire time and now
he's admitted that he was down playing
the virus okay so
i think a couple things can be true one
if trump would come out in early
february and said this thing is airborne
there was not the scientific proof to
back that up again the who only declared
this thing airborne in july
okay so it would have been crazy for
trump to say that in early february and
it is crazy frankly for him to say it to
bob woodward
he's going to be on the phone with bob
woodward my god what are you even what
do people even do at the white house
seriously just disconnect the damn
phones here
just take the phone and smash it with a
hammer and then bleach bit it like
hillary clinton
okay so that is number one number two it
is also true that the president should
not have downplayed the virus it was a
major mistake for the president to have
done that
in february march a serious mistake a
political mistake
and in fact a human mistake because you
shouldn't be telling people to downplay
particular threats when those threats
actually threaten their lives right you
shouldn't do that
now here's the thing is this actually a
revelation
two answers one if it's a revelation and
the real revelation is not what he said
on march 19th right that he wanted to
downplay it to stop panic he actually
said that publicly like a week later
in a press conference if the actual
revelation
is the february 7th conversation that he
knew early on that it was airborne
then the question becomes why bob
woodward did not release the tapes or
report it
and there's a question being asked by
left right and center why exactly if bob
woodward knew this thing was airborne
early february didn't he come out and
say the president knows it's airborne
he's lying to you
and the answer is because bob woodward
didn't know whether to take
any serious measure of what trump was
saying because again
trump engages in puffery because trump
says a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff comes out of that face
and because a lot of stuff comes out of
that face if you're bob woodward we're
to do go run
to the to the press and say trump says
it's airborne and the press will go yeah
but there's no information it's airborne
there's just trump being crazy again
the bottom line is nobody knew what was
going on including trump at the time
okay in early february trump did not
know what was going on again he said
that he got information from xi jinping
who's a very untrustworthy source
there's a lot of differential
speculation by various members of the
various political parties on exactly how
serious covet was going to be and how
bad the outbreak was going to be dr
fauci was playing it down
as of february as well because he again
did not know that this thing was going
to be a massive outbreak because nobody
knew that it was going to break across
the united states
exactly this way and when you hear
democrats say well you know we applied
for additional funding now you applied
for like a tiny bit of additional
funding
you applied for like a little bit of
additional funding funding that was so
insufficient
that actually the republicans came back
in early marching up the amount of
funding
that you that they appropriated for
coveted fighting
above what democrats requested in
february okay so those are the tapes
that are
breaking across the media and the media
are going nuts over them of course
because this is finally the tape that
brings down trump this is the tape that
brings it down from now
a couple of things one everybody i think
already baked in
that trump botched his rhetorical
handling of the virus everybody i think
has already baked that in
does that mean that this is going to
damage trump no it is going to damage
trump and again
the phone call is coming from inside the
house if you're the white house comms
office you're just that
that babysitter from the horror movie
who gets the call from the police that
the call is coming from with that
within the house you're just down the
office from trump you're like where are
these leaks coming from then you look
down the office and there's trump on the
phone
it's inexcusable it is political
malpractice it is stupidity of the
highest order and i frankly don't care
that senator lindsey graham supposedly
told trump to talk to woodward
trump is a grown man he's the president
of the united states and he's in his 70s
at a certain point you got to take
responsibility for your own decision to
speak with reporters
my goodness okay so that is that that
obviously is is high level stupidity but
could will has come back to her trump
well it hurts him in debate it hurts him
in ads
realistically speaking just assessing
the politics of the situation
it hurts him in debate and hurts him in
ads it hurts him in debate because if
joe biden is sentient
then now joe biden has a real line of
attack against trump he says you botched
covet and trump says
trump says you wouldn't have done
anything differently and he said well i
certainly wouldn't have downplayed it
for a month you admit it to bob woodward
that you downplayed it for a month
because you didn't want people to panic
and in downplaying it you didn't convey
the actual threat level to the american
people who you should trust right that's
a pretty good line
so you'll see biden use it you'll also
see this in every attack ad from now
until the election as i say okay but is
there really any content to it we're
going to assess
whether there is anything that really
adds here whether this is in fact a
bombshell or whether it's a restatement
from trump's own mouth the case that
actually has already made fairly
publicly
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about your safety
and securities there are a thousand
reasons why protecting your home matters
to you
and that's why ring has security
products for every corner of your home
inside and out here in la we are
experiencing a low-level
crime wave also a murder wave but a
low-level crime wave people stealing
boxes from porches
and and this happened to several of my
friends this is why you need ring
because then you can turn that tape over
to the police you can also make sure
that if somebody rings your doorbell
let's say they're ringing your doorbell
to decide if you are home or not because
they would like to participate in a home
invasion well then
you can check to see who exactly is
ringing the doorbell you can speak to
them as though you are home
ring is fantastic it keeps an eye on
everything on your property it prevents
bad things from happening on your
property because you are now in control
of the security on your own property
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door from anywhere with video
doorbells you can keep an eye on every
corner of your home with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams you can protect
your whole home with a ring alarm a
powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself i have ring at
home of course and i've been using it
for years because i care about
the security of my family get a special
offer on the ring welcome kit
at ringgit.com it comes with the ring
video doorbell 3 and the chime pro the
perfect way to start your ring
experience plus free two-day shipping
go to ring.com again that is ring.com
ben okay so right now basically i
i think we are now participating in a
multi-player game of gaslighting
every single person who's involved in
the story is gaslighting bob woodward
did not know
early february the thing was airborne he
didn't believe trump that this thing was
that serious otherwise he would have
revealed the story
right he has even said that he didn't
come forward with the story at this
point
because he literally did not know that
it was a big story at that point
so woodward is has answered these
particular
questions and woodward's answer he said
he did not have any signed agreement or
formal embargo arrangement with trump or
the white house to hold back their
conversations
he said i told him it was for the book
but as far as promising it not to
publish in real time
i didn't do that he said his aim was to
provide a fuller context than could
occur in a news story
i knew i could tell the second draft of
history and i could tell it before the
election
also he said that there were two
problems with what he heard from trump
in february that kept him from putting
it in the newspaper at the time won
he didn't know what the source of
trump's information was it wasn't until
months later in may
that woodward learned it came from a
high-level intelligence briefing in
january that was also described in
wednesday's reporting about the book now
note democrats had the same high-level
briefing in mid-february
so top democrats knew everything trump
knew by mid-february in february what
trump told woodward
seemed hard to make sense of the author
said back then there was no panic over
the virus even toward the final days of
that month
fout she was publicly assuring americans
there was no need to change their daily
habits
and he says the biggest problem is i
didn't know if it was true well that's
right
okay that is correct so woodward is
basically acknowledging that trump
didn't know what he was talking about
because trump
very rarely knows what he is talking
about when it comes to statements of
facts
right this is one of the reasons why his
press conferences as soon as he got off
script
devolved into kind of utter chaos and a
bizarre sort of weird benny hill routine
okay that that's because again trump is
not the greatest
conveyor of or purveyor of fact and this
has not stopped anybody from jumping to
the to the conclusion they wish to jump
to which is that trump knew full well
how bad things were in early february
and then he lied about it
okay that is not correct okay let's go
through first of all what trump's
comments look like and then we'll
parallel them
with what exactly andrew cuomo's
comments look like because as you will
see
they're kind of parallel everybody was
kind of figuring this out at the same
time
so the basic story here which is that
trump knew in february
early february everyone was going to die
from the virus and then he lied about it
so to what end exactly nobody knows
right what exactly was the end of it i
i've yet to hear an excuse for why this
would happen it's sort of like when when
the left claimed that bush lied to lie
america into war in iraq
why to to what end so we could get
involved in a in a quagmire war for for
a decade
what what exactly was the purpose if
trump was lying about the virus knowing
right
not that he made a mistake not that he
botched it by downplaying it right that
all of that
is fair game that he lied about it that
trump lied in order to do what
seriously in order to do what so he knew
early february that covert was gonna
kill everybody
and then he was just like i'm gonna
downplay it for fun like why to
to increase the stock market but as soon
as the news broke the stock market was
going to crash
why to uphold his electoral
possibilities as soon as covet hit it
was going to be obvious that trump had
misstated the case
and that was going to hurt him
politically so what would be the purpose
of the lie again i think we ought to
distinguish
between people saying dumb crap which
again is a hallmark of this
administration
and lying outright that he is not he was
not lying about covet
okay and by the way you know who says he
was not lying about covet i'm not the
one saying
he was not lying about covet dr anthony
fauci says he was not lying about covid
so here is dr anthony fauci
last night saying there wasn't any
discrepancy between what we told trump
and what he told the press
i may not be tuned in to the right thing
that they're talking about
but i didn't really see any
discrepancies between what he told
us and what we told him and what he
ultimately came out publicly and said
i didn't get any sense that he was
distorting anything i mean in my
discussions with him
they were always straightforward about
that the concerns that we had
we related that to him and uh when he
would go out and i'd hear him discussing
the same sort of things
okay so there is fouchy basically
downplaying the accusations by woodward
right fouchu specifically asked
do you think that trump can make bad
information to the public and vouchers
like no
and not only that voucher says when i
told trump to shut it down he did shut
it down
right he listened to me here's fauci the
first
and only time that dr burks and i
went in and formally made a
recommendation to the president
to actually have a quote
shut down in the sense of not really
shut down but to really have strong
mitigation we discussed it obviously
there would be concern
by some that in fact that might have
some
negative consequences nonetheless the
president listened to the recommendation
and went to the mitigation okay so
fauci himself has already kind of
debunked woodward's story but let's go
through the actual timeline here because
the case democrats are making is that
they would have handled it differently
and they handled it right and it was all
trump botching it so let's begin
with trump's comment and we'll see how
his comments evolved over time
and there's no question that he did in
fact downplay the virus
all the way until basically mid-march
here was
president trump january 22nd saying that
we have this under control
have you been briefed by the cdc are the
words about a pandemic at this point no
we're not at all and
we're we have it totally under control
it's one person
coming in from china and we have it
under control
it's uh going to be just fine on
february 7th president trump tweeted
that the chinese government had it under
control right he tweeted just had a long
and very good conversation by phone with
president xi of china he is strong sharp
powerfully focused on leading the
counter-attack on coronavirus he feels
they're doing very well even building
hospitals
in a matter of only days
not only that but he will be successful
especially as the weather starts to warm
and the virus hopefully
becomes weaker and then gone great
discipline is taking place in china as
president xi strongly leads
will be a very successful operation
we're working closely with china to help
right this is the same day that woodward
said that trump called him up
and started talking about how that thing
was airborne and how it was going to
kill everybody and it was super
dangerous
okay those two those two messages are
not in conflict by the way trump could
have thought all that and also thought
that the chinese government was actually
going to be successful in shutting it
down
february 10th trump went on at record he
said when the weather gets warmer it's
going to go away here's from february
10th at a rally
by the way the virus
they're working hard looks like by april
you know in theory when it gets a little
warmer it
miraculously goes away hope that's true
okay then february 26th president trump
reiterated he said we're very ready for
this
and the risk is low the number one
priority from our standpoint is the
health
and safety of the american people and
that's the way i viewed it when i made
that decision
because of all we've done the risk
to the american people remains very low
but we're very very ready for this for
anything whether it's
going to be a uh breakout of larger
proportions or whether or not
we're uh you know we're at that very low
level
okay february 29th president trump said
please don't incite panic right so this
is the first time you've heard this sort
of language from trump where he says
listen
we're taking it seriously but please
don't incite panic which exactly is what
he said
i mean like again he said what he said
the woodward out loud like prior to that
here he was on february 29th saying it
i'd like to just ask and caution that
the
media we would respectfully ask the
media and politicians and everybody else
involved
not do anything to incite a panic
because there's no reason to panic
at all this is something that is being
handled professionally
okay march 9th trump tweeted out
comparing it to the flu
again right so you see tweet out last
year 37 000 americans died from the
common flu it averages between 27 000
and 70 000 per year
nothing is shut down life in the economy
go on at this moment there are 546
confirmed cases of coronavirus with 22
deaths
think about that and then finally on
march 30th
president trump was asked again about
this in an interview on fox news
broadcast on fox news and he was asked
about exactly
why he had sort of not spoken with
tremendous seriousness about coronavirus
early on
and he said i didn't want anybody to
panic so basically all of the
revelations in woodward's book were out
there in public view so this isn't
really a revelation here was trump
this would have been march 30th the
statements i made are i want to keep the
country calm
i don't want panic in the country i
could cause panic much better than even
you
i could do much i would make you look
like a minor league player
but you know what i don't want to do
that i want to have our country be calm
and strong and fight and win and it will
go away
okay so again that was trump on march
30th so all that sounds like downplaying
down playing down playing don't panic
don't panic and
now i'm taking it seriously right that
again everything that he said to
woodward behind the scenes he was also
saying out loud in front of the scenes
because this is also typical trump right
third rule of trump
anything you say behind the scenes will
eventually be let out in public by trump
in a second we're gonna see that the
democrats mirrored this exact
pattern okay this is not just trump the
democrats mirrored this exact pattern
for all the talk about they were on top
of this
and trump's response was criminal and he
was lying
the democrats were doing the exact same
thing again this doesn't mean anybody
handles it right it just means everybody
handles it wrong
we're gonna get to this in one second
first you know how strongly i believe in
individual liberty and personal
responsibility our founding fathers knew
these were the cornerstones of a great
civilization which is why they believed
that the second amendment was necessary
in order to protect
our rights our right to protect
ourselves protect our rights protect our
families
that said if you're gonna own a rifle
it's an awesome responsibility and
building rifles is no different
that's why i am impressed with bravo
company manufacturing the people at
bravo company mfg they support the right
of responsible
private individuals to have the access
and ability to employ the same tools
as civilian law enforcement as a means
of defending ourselves
our loved ones our communities and our
freedoms should a threatening situation
ever arise
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a life or
death situation
their rifles are not made for target
shooting or for hunting primarily they
are made so you can defend
yourself and defend your rights as an
american you have the luxury of living
in a free society where you can improve
at your life every american is
responsible for questioning debating
confronting the issues that affect our
lives and
if god forbid your life is threatened
you are responsible for protecting your
own life
as well this is the first and foremost
primary right that adheres to you as a
human being and bcm
is out to protect it to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing
head on over to bravocompanymfg.com you
can discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that is
bravocompanymfg.com if you need more
convincing find out even more about bcm
and the awesome people who make their
products at youtube.com
bravo company usa and that's
bravocompanymfg.com
so naturally the democrats have
responded and the media have responded
to the
news of president trump's revelation
here with shock and awe
they can't believe it carl bernstein who
literally just walks around
saying that uh that everything is worse
than watergate says wait for it wait for
it
this is worse than watergate here's
bernstein explaining this is worse than
watergate
it's going to be very hard to see how
this cannot be addressed by
republicans in particular and their
candidate for president of the united
states the last time this happened
during nixon's the end of nixon's
presidency the republican leadership
including barry goldwater the 1964
nominee of his party for president
went to the white house and told nixon
he had to resign
and the facts here are even greater than
in watergate
okay all bernstein has done for his
entire life is just say watergate over
and over because it's his big
accomplishment
but at a certain point the high school
quarterback is going to have to get a
new career
i mean seriously like you just said it's
worse than more it's not worse than
watergate it's not worse than watergate
as we'll see
every democrat down played this thing
yeah they did and nobody knew how bad
this was going to be
and again i don't even understand the
implication the implication is
supposedly that trump lied about this
that he outright lied the implication is
that no again not that he botched it not
that he made a mistake not that he has a
congenital habit
of downplaying bad news and up playing
good news which he does
but that he actively lied about kovit
that he knew it was going to kill tons
of people and then he lied to the
american public so that what more people
would die and the economy would get
worse and he would lose all faith in the
presidency like it makes no sense at all
to suggest you know first degree lying
here purposeful lying in any case
cnn went nuts on this as well so cnn's
brianna keeler cut off kaylee mcinanny
because kaylee mcinerney suggested that
um that in fact the president had not
downplayed
the virus which of course is not true
the president has now admitted on tape
to
downplaying the virus here was uh kaylee
mackinani uh and being cut off by cnn
we didn't want so there to be a huge
crash in panic he expressed
calmness from this podium but he has
always taken it seriously and the
response
and unprecedented response really
reflects that yes
so thanks kaylee um i wanted to ask you
about the
astrazeneca trial so does that throw a
spanner in the works that they've halted
their trials in terms of getting a
vaccine
all right that was a press secretary at
the white house lying
well well there's some solid media
coverage right there because not the job
of the press secretary to spin
apparently press secretaries never spin
except for the ones who work for trump
other than that they are absolute
truth-tellers unvarnished unglossed
truth from press secretaries ranging
from
jay carney to robert gibbs all the way
back to ra fly for sure cnn's pamela
brown
then grilled senator john kennedy from
from louisiana
asking how he could be okay with this
here's how this went
let me say a word about about this
infatuation in washington with who said
what to whom
i learned pretty quickly up here senator
i'm sorry i'm not going to let you do
this okay this is
i understand there's so much politics
right now we're two months away from an
election
but this is life and death you had five
thousand people
that have died in louisiana from
coronavirus
republicans are reluctant as you are now
to ever criticize this president but as
a human being
how can you be okay with this okay again
what is it that
people are supposedly okay with i mean
it's pretty obvious that trump should
have said more serious things about the
virus early
but aside from that is there and that's
the thing i mean it is okay but
aside from that are we going to pretend
that the democrats had any response to
this because they did not
they did in fact oppose the chinese
travel ban the amount of spending they
proposed to spend on this thing was like
a billion dollars
one billion okay we ended up spending
seven trillion
on it minimum okay they proposed
originally one billion dollars for like
some studies and a little bit of ppe
when they say that if trump had taken it
more seriously everybody would have
messed up in february nonsense
the cdc was legitimately telling
everybody not to mask up in february
so what exactly would have changed here
so i've heard a couple of
recommendations
as to what would have changed we should
have done better with the ppe we should
have ramped up ppe production
okay there's only one problem china had
a monopoly on ppe production and they
were util
and they'd seized all of it so that's
problem number one
number two if trump had taken it more
seriously maybe people would have
started sheltering in place
a little bit earlier but democratic
mayors and governors didn't tell anybody
to shelter in place
earlier either and in fact democratic
legislators who knew full well what was
going on because they were getting the
same intelligence briefings on the stuff
that trump was
they were spending most of february down
playing the thing as well i mean dr
fauci was downplaying it in late
february
like don't let people rewrite the
history here such that trump was
fully in the know about how bad this was
going to be february 7th as opposed to
just engaging in puffery
with with woodward which is exactly what
he was doing in early february we've all
watched trump we all know what he's
doing
that doesn't matter the democrats have
responded by basically suggesting that
trump is a criminal here was joe biden
suggesting that trump's response was
criminal
even though again joe biden has yet to
explain what he would have done
differently
it's amazing there's never a follow-up
question what would you have done
differently joe biden
ever and he just refers back to it
editorial he wrote
in january like january 27th where he
said coronavirus is bad
that's the entire editorial there's
nothing in there about what he would
actually do
it was just coronavirus is a bad thing
thanks joe okay but here was joe biden
with
jake tapper saying that trump's response
was criminal and again this is gonna be
the pattern from now until the election
some allegation will be made about trump
and biden will be asked about trump
biden will never be asked about biden
ever right now you would expect a
journalist at some point to ask joe
biden what would you do differently what
would your plans look like
what exactly if you were president what
would you have changed but nobody will
ever ask him that because he's a
democrat so instead it's going to be
here's a revelation about trump what do
you think about that revelation joe here
was joe biden going
off on trump it was all about making
sure the stock market didn't come down
that his wealthy friend didn't lose any
money and that he could say
that in fact anything that happened had
nothing to do with him
he waved a white flag he walked away he
didn't do a damn thing
think about it think about what he did
not do
and it's almost criminal okay what he
did not do
he gave the governors the ventilators
they need he did ramp up ppe production
it was the cdc that botched the testing
regimen okay those are career staffers
at the cdc when he says that he did this
to
what uphold the market for his rich
friends what are you talking about
seriously what are you talking about the
market crashed the market tanked in
march
absolutely blew out right what what are
you
what like that doesn't even make any
sense
and when joe biden sits there and he
suggests that donald trump did this for
his rich friends i mean that is a form
of slander it really is
because there is no evidence to suggest
that that is the case whatsoever by the
way
who is holding rallies into early march
but like big rallies into early march
captain i'm taking it seriously over
here who is holding big rallies oh yeah
that was right it was joe biden
who's holding rallies in march before he
uh before he passed away and was wheeled
around as a corpse he was doing public
rallies in march
nancy pelosi also did this routine
yesterday said trump downplayed the
threat he's now admitted to down playing
the threat
she tweeted out trump and republicans
downplayed the deadly threat of the
coronavirus moscow mitch i mean
now we're all just twitter trolls
decided to take a pause rather than help
the american people with a strategic
plan
don't be misled their failure and denial
are costing lies i have a question
wasn't she speaker of the house at the
time
what did she do i'll tell you what she
did on february 24th she went down to
chinatown
and she told everybody to join her down
in chinatown in san francisco
as the pandemic began here's nancy
pelosa nancy pelosi started february
24th
speaker nancy pelosi told me she came
here to chinatown to combat
fear that's what we're trying to do
today is to say everything is
fine here she understands people are
concerned about china
but that shouldn't be carried over to
chinatown and san francisco
i hope that it's not that but all i can
say is
i'm here we feel safe and sound so many
of us
coming here okay so again
the the notion that democrats were
really on top of this or would have been
on top of this if they had the
information from
it's just nonsense it's just nonsense
this is once again trump's mouth coming
back to bite him on the ass but that's
pretty much all you got here
and all the implications you're drawing
that he was lying to uphold these rich
friends that is that is ridiculous
ridiculous and frankly slanderous we'll
get some more of this in
just one second because we'll show you
how america's best governor
andrew cuomo we've been informed by
those who know that he's an incredible
governor
that andrew cuomo really captain on top
of this thing
he went on top of this thing i'll show
you again this is just an indicator of
where everybody was because
i can't blame people for not being super
serious about this in february i wasn't
super serious about this in february
because nobody was super serious about
this in february
they were not don't let people rewrite
history it was early march when people
started to get worried
like truly worried including fouchy now
the people who they're now they're now
buying votive candles
a vouch fouchy but back in february he
wasn't taking it super seriously either
we'll get some more of this in just one
second but first getting in shape
doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale it's about building
a healthier habits feeling better about
yourself if fitting into that favorite
pair of jeans is your goal that's great
but there are a lot of reasons
why you might want to practice self-care
every person is different so
when this pandemic began i could see the
possibility of a pandemic 15 in my
future and so i really ramped up
my new muse what it allowed me to do was
take little steps every single day
to control exactly how i was eating how
i was exercising
tracking everything i was doing it gave
me psychological tips every day
on how to keep up with it because your
energy tends to flag while you're doing
this stuff while you're changing your
habits and that's what newm can do for
you it helps you change your habits
day to day it's a habit changing
solution it helps users learn to develop
a new relationship with food through
personalized courses
based in psychology new will teach you
why you do the things you do and empower
you with the tools you need to break bad
habits and replace them
with better ones no food is good bad or
off-limits newm teaches moderation can
be used in conjunction with many
pre-existing popular diets
if you want to it won't tell you what to
do and what not to do instead it teaches
you to sort of retrain
how you think about food they have a
great accurate food database that lets
you track meal habits visualize portion
sizes to see calorie density at a glance
you can know exactly what you're putting
into your body you don't have to change
all this in one day small steps make big
progress sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
shapiro again that's noom.com to start
that trial today get healthier
visit noom.com shapiro we'll get to a a
reminder as to what the democratic
response was throughout the cove
pandemic and then we'll get to the
continued politicization of covet
because it's
it's insipid well we'll continue this in
one second first
you're a part of our daily ware audience
and that means there are a number of
ways to take in our podcast you can
listen on apple podcast spotify another
podcast app
you can also watch our podcast at
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com
here's the bottom line we are making our
content available to you anywhere you
want to watch or listen
and now we are introducing a new
upgraded experience daily wire is now on
apple tv and roku so members can enjoy
all the visual elements on this podcast
on your big screen either live or on
demand
find the daily wire on apple tv or roku
and download today
you have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout to
get 15 off your membership purchase
the deal's not gonna last long act fast
if you want live shows on your big
screen plus the one of a kind highly
coveted leftist tears tumblr again that
is dailywire.com
shapiro to get 15 off with codewatch
download the daily wire on your apple tv
and roku today also if you have not yet
seen
the bench spiritual sunday special we
are back we are better than ever last
week we had candace owns you may have
seen that went viral when she went after
cardi b this sunday we're featuring dan
bongino it's a great conversation make
sure to keep an ear out for it
this sunday you are listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so how do democrats respond to
this again this is the big question
if trump supposedly blew this right if
trump knew all the way back when
that in order for democrats to claim
that trump did something super wrong
here he didn't just blow it
they have to claim two things one either
that they knew and they would have
handled it better which
they can't claim or two that trump knew
and he lied
trump knew any lies what they're going
for with this woodward revelation but
again the evidence ain't there
that trump knew it was airborne that
trump knew it was super dangerous just
because he said to woodward what he had
heard from
xi jinping february 7th that's called
trump mouthing off he does that crap all
the time
right this is the same guy who went out
in the middle of a press conference and
he was like
uv light i've heard that it kills things
what if we could find a way to get it
inside the body
it's like okay you're just saying stuff
now
it's amazing to me how many people will
take trump
absolutely literally and seriously and
again i get this all the time
you took obama literally yes because
obama was a literal serious person i'm
sorry to tell you this but i'm not going
to treat donald trump the same way that
i treat barack obama because they don't
think the same
they don't act the same that is like
saying i'm gonna treat my wife the same
way i treat my baby that is not the same
thing
okay and you may say that soft bigotry
of low expectations fine call it
whatever you want i have very low
expectations for trump's rhetorical
prowess when it comes to
spitting out solid facts or how
seriously he takes his own rhetoric and
i think that the record will back me on
this
okay that doesn't mean that trump is a
bad president it doesn't mean that trump
hasn't done a great many things that i
like as president of the united states
it doesn't even mean that i don't plan
on voting for him it does mean that if
you are asking me to take his comments
with tremendous
seriousness i don't know what world
you're living in and why
why would i what evidence do i have this
is a man who today
today tweeted out that kim jong-un i
hope he's feeling better
he's a real fighter like what in the
world is going on
trump tweeted out moments ago kim
jong-un is in good health never
underestimate him
never underestimate kim jong-un like
that's the guy i'm supposed to take
how do you how do you muster the outrage
on a day after day basis how
like i understand mustering outrage it's
somebody who actually has the capacity
for intent but how do you muster outrage
at donald trump who just says things
who suffers from tremendous tremendously
serious logaria how do you
okay in any case the other case the
democrats could make
is that they they would have treated
this better or they didn't treat this
better and that's just a lie
so let's track the rhetoric of andrew
cuomo the greatest of all governors
right we've already said that nancy
pelosi is saying well we i we were
taking a very serious
late february nancy you're out in
chinatown you've already heard joe biden
saying that he was taking it super
seriously early march was out doing
rallies
until the actual shutdowns so let's
trace andrew cuomo how did he do
rhetorically speaking well here is
andrew cuomo the governor of new york on
february 2nd explaining there is no
reason to panic
we've been through situations like this
before we're very proactive
i don't take anything for granted
precaution
is always the best practice
preparedness is always the best practice
and that's what we do here in new york
at the same time we have to keep this in
perspective there is no reason to panic
there's no reason to have an
an inordinate amount of fear about this
situation
okay fast forward a month has much
changed the answer is no here is andrew
cuomo on march 2nd
remember this is when democrats are
saying that we're taking it super
seriously and republicans are not here's
andrew cuomo march second saying we have
a great health care system it's not
going to be that bad here and don't
worry we'll take care of the nursing
homes how has this comment now come back
to auntie andrew cuomo considering 11
000 people died in nursing homes because
he was shipping
elderly coveted ridden patients back
into nursing homes here's andrew cuomo
circled march 2.
we think we have the best health care
system
on the planet right here in new york
so when you're saying what happened in
other countries versus what happened
here
we don't even think it's going to be as
bad as it was in other countries
we are fully coordinated we are fully
mobilized
this is all about mobilization of a
public health system
that is going to be primarily senior
citizens
people who are debilitated and we're
going to have a special effort for our
nursing homes
etc okay then the next day he says by
the way we can't contain the spread but
we shouldn't be too concerned about the
fact that we can't contain this but
again this is march 3rd
okay this is not february 7th this is
not january this is march 3rd
you cannot contain the spread you can
slow it you can limit it
but you can't contain it
that isn't a cause for anxiety either
because
well what happens when a large number of
people get infected
which you're going to see a spread by
the way i said
uh two weeks ago it's just a matter of
time
before we see our first case then we saw
our first case
i said yesterday you will see a case of
community spread
here we are today there's a case of
okay so again it took another week and a
half for him to start taking it
seriously and it took him another three
weeks to fully shut down
the state of new york so many things can
be true simultaneously trump botched the
rhetoric
trump shouldn't have taken it lightly in
terms of how he spoke about this
publicly
democrats had no plan they presented no
plan and nothing really fundamentally
would have changed if a democrat had
been president
democratic governors botched this thing
royally including andrew cuomo
is it a bombshell or is this just
another revelation of stuff that we
already knew the answer is the latter it
is not in fact bombshell and i did that
at length because i think it is
important
for people to recognize how the media
spin up what is a thing we already knew
namely trump says stuff
and that he was saying silly stuff about
covid and and he should have taken this
more seriously in february and march
okay how they spin that up into a new
scandal just two months before the
election at the behest
presumably of the biden campaign and
then allow biden to get away with public
statements like trump did this
in order in order to increase the stock
market which is just conspiratorial
nonsense of the highest order
now this is also relevant because the
politicization of kovid continues
right we are continuing to watch the
politicization of kovid
and some people are making this
perfectly obvious so barbara farrar is
the l.a county
health official who's been in charge of
coveted policy she was caught on a phone
call
explaining full out that uh the schools
would not be open until after the
election which sounds just a little
political does it not
so we don't realistically anticipate
that we would be moving either tier two
or
to reopening uh k-12 schools at least
through
uh at least until after the election
after you know in early november like
when we just look at the timing of
everything
it seems to us a more realistic approach
to this would be to think that we're
going to be where we are
now until uh we get after
until we we are done with the elections
okay so the
i mean this is very political and and
the media coverage of code is very
political
so for example there's a story from the
associated press called
teacher deaths raise alarm as new school
year begins
okay this is from the associated press
teachers in at least three states have
died after bats with covet since the
dawn of the new school year
and a teacher's union leader worries
that the return to in-person classes
will have a deadly impact across the us
if proper precautions aren't taken now
you might gather from that headline that
basically a bunch of teachers went back
to school and kids infected them
and then they died there's only one
problem the stories that are cited by
the ap
are cases where the teachers obtained
the virus from places that are not
children
in oxford mississippi 42 year old nakoma
james taught in middle school and helped
coach high school football
he died august 6th during the first week
of classes but was
self-quarantining when teachers and
students returned to the classroom so he
already had it
right well the the cases it didn't come
from the workout
from the kids apparently another
mississippi teacher died on sunday
history teacher tom slade recently
posted on facebook about his battle with
pneumonia caused by the coronavirus
slade was teaching in person when the
academic year started august 16th but
began quarantining after he had contact
with someone who was positive at a
church meeting right so he's not in fact
at school
in south carolina demetria demi
bannister 28 died three days after being
diagnosed
with covet 19. the district banister was
at
windsor elementary school said they said
that she was at the elementary school
august 28th for a teacher work day
before classes resumed before classes
was resumed
in person classes started august 24th
but she was already hospitalized
by then so um
why are so the suggestion is that
school's opening is going to be the
big vector of transmission that's three
cases cited by the ap of teachers dying
none of whom obtained this thing at
school apparently or if they did it was
from adults
okay that is biased media coverage in
the extreme in the extreme
and meanwhile speaking of bias media
coverage in the extreme the media are
making hay out of the fact that the
astrazeneca trial
has been put on hold they are suggesting
this is because of an unexplained side
effect
that is not what happened here what
happened is that somebody who was in the
control group was somebody who's taking
the vaccine
not in the control group somebody who's
taking the vaccine in the vaccine group
came down
with something they don't know whether
it was linked to the vaccine yet or not
but the scare tactic is well maybe
they've identified a grave side effect
that causes them to cancel the trial
that is not the way this works
okay they called it a routine action
quote is francis collins director of the
national institutes of health
the announcement yesterday about the
astrozenica vaccine is a concrete
example
of how even a single case of an
unexpected illness is sufficient to
require a clinical hold for the trial
in multiple counties okay so the but the
media played this as though this was an
unexplained
side effect in fact in fact astrozenica
spokesman brendan mcavoy said the event
is being investigated by an independent
committee it is too early to conclude
any specific diagnosis so it is unclear
whether this is even linked to the
vaccine at this point
but the media ran with that anyway to to
suggest that the vaccines are not going
to work
we have also seen we've also seen the
media continue to trot out this
ridiculous
sturgis study suggesting that there were
267 000 covet cases and 12.2 billion
dollars in public health costs attached
to the sturgis motorcycle rally
in south dakota it's nonsense i mean
it's ridiculous the washington post
reported
like a week ago that there were 260
confirmed cases connected to sturgis
according to the wall street journal
editorial board many in the media and
various health stages warned that the
motorcycle rally represented a
worst-case scenario for a super
spreading event
it would be surprising if the rally
didn't lead to at least some new coveted
cases it's impossible to know how many
because there's no data on how many
attendees or their close contacts later
tested positive but don't worry the
modelers showed up
so what exactly did they do well they
analyzed the anonymous cell phone data
of attendees and then they compared case
trends in counties with high moderate
and low numbers of attendees they found
that cases increased by 3.6 to 3.9
percent
3.6 to 3.9 sorry per 1 000 in south
dakota
in the three weeks after the rally
translating to between
3185 and 3441 more cases statewide
to put this number in perspective new
york state has recorded as many cases in
the last week
even with its stringent public health
rules south dakota still has among the
lowest per capita death rates
in america coveted patients currently
occupy three percent
of the state hospital beds and six
percent of icu beds
the study really jumps off the rails by
linking all relative increase in virus
cases in counties with attendees
compared to those without rally
participants again many high inflow
counties like los angeles maricopa clark
and el paso
had already been experiencing flare-ups
so basically the modeler said if la
experienced a flare-up
after sergius then it was probably
surgis that's crazy
la's been experiencing a flare-up for
weeks for months at this point
these counties may have shared other
characteristics like high population
density says the wall street journal
that contributed to the increases
there could also be other endogenous
variables for example counties with more
people who attended the motorcycle rally
may also have had populations less
observant of social distancing
doesn't matter they also then assigned a
cost of 46 000
per person identified with the case to
get to 12.2 billion
which is crazy the vast majority of
people who get coveted get mild or
asymptomatic cases
so what what in the hell but this study
was trotted out
as the gold standard for showing that it
was red states that were responsible for
everything evil
happening in the country right now this
is all highly political
how highly political is it la county
tried to ban trick-or-treating
it's it's currently september 10th last
night checks halloween has not been
changed from its original date of
october 31st
which means that they are banning
trick-or-treating seven weeks out
seven weeks out and by the way
trick-or-treating does not convey the
virus you're outdoors you're socially
distant what the hell are you talking
about
they had to walk it back instead they
said the activity is quote unquote
not recommended door-to-door
trick-or-treating is not recommended
because it can be very difficult to
maintain proper social distancing on
porches and at front doors
ensure that everyone answering or coming
to the door is appropriately masked to
prevent disease and because sharing food
is risky okay first of all you're
generally sharing like packaged candy
you know we're not halloween celebrators
in the shapiro family but we do leave
out like a bucket
of candy for the kids everybody can do
that this is not that difficult
the con the county is also advising
against trunk or treating that is going
to a
car to car to receive candy so they
tried to cancel this and then the cops
were like you know we're not enforcing
this and then they
walk it back so really really well done
everybody is doing a great job with all
of this
okay meanwhile it is worth noting that
uh there are some other takeaways from
the woodward book that have been making
some news
some of the takeaways from the woodward
brook that have been making some news
well there's some revelations about
things that people supposedly said that
they've now denied
so they suggest that dr fauci said that
trump has no attention span which by the
way
trump has no attention span i mean i'll
just say it straight out i i don't get
the impression trump has a
very long attention span to you not from
his twitter account
uh apparently fauci also suggested uh
that trump
didn't really follow the data all that
well which again we kind of knew
considering that we already knew that he
has
like shrunk his intelligence briefings
down to a single page in any case
douche was asked about this on fox news
and he said i didn't say any of that
according to the washington post fauci
at one point tells others
that the president quote is on a
separate channel and unfocused in
meetings with quote rudderless
leadership according to woodward
is it quote his attention span is like a
minus number fouch he said according to
woodward
his sole purpose is to get re-elected
right um
is that correct you know if you notice
it was
others have said that yeah so you know
you should ask
others i don't recall that at all okay
so there was fouchy debunking that claim
then there was the claim that jim mattis
called trump dangerous and unfit which
again is not a great shot considering
that he quit over syria policy and wrote
a letter to that effect
and dan coats the former director of
national intelligence apparently
at some point he uh he said that trump's
gentle approach
to russia reflected something more
sinister perhaps that moscow had
something okay so that was speculation
from dan coats this is all gossipy
behind closed doors kind of stuff
apparently trump repeatedly denigrated
senior american military officials to
his trade advisory so they care more
about alliances than they do about trade
deals
in a discussion with woodward trump
called the us military suckers for
paying extensive costs
to protect south korea what a road he
was done when the president said of
south korea we're defending you
or allowing you to exist okay again
trump has said all of this publicly that
is not a revelation
my favorite supposed revelation from the
woodward book is one that actually makes
trump look a lot better
and that is where bob woodward pointed
out that he and trump were quote white
and privileged and asked if trump was
working to understand the pain
anger and particularly black people feel
in this country and trump said no
and then he said you really drank the
kool-aid didn't you listen to me wow no
i don't feel that at all
honestly good for trump the fact that he
spent 18 hours on the phone
with this credulous dupe woodward
is uh is pretty astonishing to me in the
first place but if you're going to do
with that conversation then at the very
least you can
you can point out the nonsense when it
comes up
woodward also apparently uh gained
insight into trump's relationships with
north korea
in describing his chemistry with kim
trump said quote
you meet a woman in one second you know
whether whether or not it's going to
happen
that's not good and also weird
also he complained about the in the
russia investigations he said putin said
to me in a meeting
it's a shame because i know it's very
hard for you to make a deal with us i
said you're right
okay again that is not really revelation
so not a lot of revelations happening
from the from the woodward book
certainly not in the way
that uh the media seem to be covering it
meanwhile adam schiff
is trying to revive his allegations that
somehow
trump is impeachable so remember he
tried last time and he failed
well he's back again is adam shift or as
the president calls him shifty shift
he is back again now he has announced
that as part of its ongoing
investigation into the dhs and the
office of intelligence and analysis
the committee received a whistleblower
reprisal complaint alleging serious
wrongdoing by officials at the
department
and reprisal against former ina acting
under secretary brian murphy for making
protected disclosures
after receiving the complaint shift sent
a letter requesting murphy appear for a
deposition
schiff released a statement the
whistleblower retaliation complaint
filed by former acting under secretary
for intelligence and analysis brian
murphy
outlines grave and disturbing
allegations that senior white house and
department of homeland security
officials
improperly sought to politicize
manipulate and censor intelligence in
order to benefit president trump
politically this puts our nation and its
security at grave risk
murphy's allegations are serious from
senior officials suppressing
intelligence reports on russia's
election interference and making false
statements to congress about terrorism
threats at our southern border to
modifying intelligence assessments
to match the president's rhetoric on
antifa and minimizing the threat
posed by white supremacists we've
requested murphy's testimony so
in other words this is just a guy who's
a career staffer who disagrees with how
the intelligence community
was creating its assessments and now is
claiming that trump intimidated them
presumably without any evidence of any
of this so good we can have another full
investigation of this
maybe we can try to um maybe we can try
to
impeach again because that worked out so
well last time
suffice to say democrats are are drawing
near the bottom of the well
at this point now does that mean that
trump is going to win
no i mean it doesn't mean that trump is
going to win it doesn't mean that
they won't be effective enough for for
biden to carry himself over the finish
line
it does mean that when you're going back
to the well with adam schiff and looking
for impeachable offenses
you're really really digging near the
bottom
all right we'll be back here a little
bit later today with much more
additional content so stick around for
that otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clayton
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton